They say Kiev was
always Russian,
but that's not
history, that's
just propaganda.
In 1882, Prince
Oleg seized Kiev
and founded the
Kiev and Rus.
Moscow?
Still a swamp.
Fast forward to
1547, Tsar Ivan
IV proclaims
himself Tsar of
all of Rus, a
PR stunt to
steal
Kiev's legacy.
Muscovy doubles
down with myths
like tales of the
princes of
Vladimir
linking Moscow
to
Byzantium and Rome.
Fast forward to
2021, Putin wrote
an essay where he
claims that
Ukrainians are
just Russians,
and in 2022 an
invasion follows.
Shared roots do
not equal
ownership, Kiev
was not always
Russian.
Don't let fake
history win, like
and follow for
more sub-60 seconds
myth busting.